Salut, aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une petite anecdote sur quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien,
et pourtant quand je vais dire son nom ça ne va pas vous parler.
Il s'agit de Charles Dodgson.
Je ne pense pas que ça vous dise grand chose...
En 1862, un jour, pour s'occuper il raconte à 3 frangines, 3 soeurs,
une histoire de ouf.
Une histoire qu'il invente.
Dans son histoire il emmène la protagoniste dans un terrier de lapin et il la fait tomber dans un trou,
et à ce moment là, il a aucune idée de ce qui va arriver à la fille.
Ca par contre ça doit vous rappeler quelque chose.
Et sur les 3 soeurs à qui il racontait cette histoire, il était amoureux de l'une d'entre elles.
Alors pour essayer de marquer des points et lui faire plaisir, il a appelé son héroine, comme la fille qu'il aimait, c'est-à-dire Alice.
Et cette fameuse Alice, la vraie, celle qui existait vraiment, elle lui a demandait d'écrire l'histoire sur une feuille.
Parce qu'elle avait bien aimé le début.
Et donc il a écrit cette histoire pour cette fille là qu'il aimait.
C'est ainsi que Dogdson a écrit Alice aux Pays des Merveilles.
Qui est l'un de mes romans préférés.
Il l'a écrit sous le pseudonyme de Lewis Carroll qui n'est pas du tout son vrai nom.
La fille en question celle qui existe s'appelle Alice Liddell.
Dans la suite de l'histoire qui a été publié en 1871, "De l'autre coté du miroir",
Lewis Carroll a caché un acrostiche.
Un acrostiche, c'est quand tu prends la première lettre de chaque mot et ça forme un nouveau mot
ou même une phrase.
Parce exemple Fabien A Biarritz, ça ferrait F-A-B, ça ferrait FAB.
Tu voit l'idée.
Et bien dans la version originale de "l'autre coté du miroir", c'est-à-dire la version en anglais, il y a un endroit où il y a un acrostiche
et si on prend les premières lettres de chaque mot, on retrouve: Alice Pleasance Liddell
Qui était le nom complet de la vraie Alice.
J'espère que cette petite anecdote littéraire vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de liker,
là en ce moment, on est sur une vidéo tous les deux jours, jusqu'au 30 aout.
Vous pouvez aussi vous abonner pour ne pas les rater.
Et puis moi je vous dit bonnes vacances !
Si vous êtes en vacances.
Et à après-demain !
[musique]